we pray with me
spirit of the Living God come now and
grow our faith deepen our hope and
strengthen our love and inspire within
each one of us the desire to be your
faithful friends forever amen so three
feet of snow and three weeks later we
are picking up the Gospel reading again
right after the baptism of Jesus you may
remember how the heavens were opened and
the Spirit of God descended like a dove
and the voice proclaimed you are my son
the beloved in whom I am well pleased
it's been a couple weeks it might be
fuzzy but you remember right you're with
me so here comes Jesus just up from the
Jordan he is full of the Holy Spirit and
still ringing the river out of his
clothes when Luke reports that he is led
by the spirit into the wilderness for 40
days where he is tested by the adversary
I was reminded of that opening scene
from the book of job do you know it
where God is beaming and bragging over
job there's no one like him and all the
earth says God a blameless and upright
man who fears God and turns away from
evil God is gushing with pride and then
the Satan this sort of litigator of the
heavenly courts pipes up and volunteers
to try the strength of jobs jobs
fidelity almost on a kind of wager here
with no introduction this same character
shows up again this time to put Jesus on
trial and to see how he fares he kicks
off this incredibly witty and calculated
jousting match with Jesus so all of you
debaters and mock trailers will probably
want to take a few notes Jesus hasn't
eaten a thing for 40 days out in the
wilderness he's in the middle of the
desert and so this adversary is a
cunning devil
all he suggests very casually if you're
the Son of God why don't you command
that stone to become a loaf of bread
it's a pretty mildly reasonable request
it's also a challenge that cuts straight
into the heart of Jesus's identity and
his authority the heavens were parted
the Dove descended it was proclaimed you
are my son and so here the Satan starts
to probe very subtly into what exactly
that means you've been in the wilderness
for 40 days without food Moses led God's
people through the wilderness for 40
years and God provided water out of the
rock and bread from heaven since you are
the son of God you must be able to feed
the Sheep provide for all of the people
and their bodily needs command that
stone to become a loaf of bread be the
new Moses and lead your people into
freedom if you feed them they will
follow you Jesus replies it is written
one does not live by bread alone it's
rather Curt and dismissive but the devil
seems unfazed he just presses on he
drags Jesus up to the mountaintop where
they gaze down over all the kingdoms of
the world and Satan says worship me and
I will give you all their authority
David was the shepherd who became king
The Anointed One chosen by God David
defeated the giant without any armor at
all and United all of Israel around
Jerusalem God established his throne
forever Jerusalem is rightly yours and
Rome to in all of the kingdoms of the
world you can have them without armor I
will give them to you and you can be the
new David to unite Israel once more in
peace the people will love you and they
will fear you and they will follow you
Jesus replies it is written worship the
Lord your God and serve only him so
finally the devil drags him
to Jerusalem places him on the pinnacle
of the temple the central seat of the
religious authority for all of Israel
and says if you are the son of God throw
yourself down and here Satan gets a
little bit snarky for it is written God
will command the angels to protect you
they will bear you up and you will not
dash your foot against a stone if Jesus
wants to play with parables out of the
Bible then Satan can quote scripture as
well as the next guy and he starts
throwing it right back at him and says
the chief priests and the elders they
ruled the religious world of Israel they
narrate the story of God and the
people's place in it but you are the son
of God challenge the chief priests take
on the temple reveal your true identity
before all the people if you stun them
with signs and with miracles the people
will love you and they will fear you and
they will follow you and Jesus closes
with this last line it is said do not
put the Lord your God to the test and
suddenly the test is over this is the
kind of double entendre that makes
rhetoric geeks like me do a little dance
it reads just like a proverb just in
that same kind of short school lesson
format that all of his other responses
do but it functions like a command do
not put the Lord your God to the test
and it's done Jesus might as well have
said I am the lord your god do not put
me to the test we read this story over
and over traditionally as a source of
evil tempting Jesus to betray God in
order to gain power we here in Jesus's
words expressions of human faithfulness
and obedience to God but in fact in his
mouth they are God's words to us all
along hovering just behind Jesus's
responses is the heart
of Deuteronomy it's the core identity
and relationship of the people of God
Israel with God it follows just after
the Shema if you're familiar with it
it's that fundamental confession of
Jewish faith hear o Israel the Lord is
our God the Lord alone and so Jesus is
pulling from Deuteronomy just after the
Shema saying remember the long way the
Lord your God has led you these forty
years in the wilderness in order to
Humble you testing you to know what was
in your heart whether or not you would
keep his Commandments God humbled you by
letting you hunger and then by feeding
you with manna in order to make you
understand that one does not live by
bread alone but by every word that comes
from the mouth of God take care that you
do not forget the Lord who brought you
out of the house of Egypt out of the
house of slavery the lord your god you
shall fear him alone shall you serve do
not follow other gods any of the gods of
the people around you these are the
words that Moses was speaking to the
people of God just as they were on the
cusp of inheriting the promised land
they were getting ready to cross over
into the land that they had been waiting
for for 40 years and Moses is speaking
these words of wisdom and encouragement
and guidance before they go into that
place but here they're no longer Moses's
words to this ancient people in some
foreign place they are in the mouth of
Jesus God's words to us today suddenly
the tables are turned it is not Jesus
who is being put on trial to determine
his faithfulness but we are with all of
our misguided and short-sighted
expectations of who the son of God will
be Jesus is the Son of God and he is
bidding us follow me but we like to
follow other kinds of God's we follow
God's who promised to feed and entertain
us to keep us satisfied
consistently and deposit us comfortably
in a land flowing with milk and honey
where we will live happily ever after or
we prefer to follow God's who promised
to stop the violence and the chaos of
the world by any means necessary God's
who promised to unite us in a sort of
hand-holding peace and grant us the
safety and security that we want at the
cost of our own agency we preferred to
follow God's who will pronounce our
forgiveness and bless the status quo of
our lives without demanding anything
different from us or disrupting any of
the systems that benefit us but here
Jesus is reminding us repeatedly over
and over with these illusions that God
wants so much more for us in our lives
God has freed and feet fed God's people
in order to teach them how to live in
full communion with God with each other
with all of creation it's not about
self-satisfaction it's so that they can
learn to live as a humble and loving
community the promised land in
perpetuity is not actually about
defining borders and controlling the
security but that they might be a
blessing to the world they are invited
but not compelled to be there worship is
not about applying the rules to
determine who is in and who is out but
that other people might see their
community in Jubilee celebration and
long so desperately to be a part of it
and then to find delightfully that they
too are invited in Jesus invites us into
that covenant community that covenant
with God and with each other Jesus
invites us to leave behind all of our
shabby little shell self-made gods in
order to follow him but it's a way
without a clear map which makes some of
us nervous the nice thing is that we
have a clear leader Jesus leads us into
this kind of
risky business of trying to be God's
people in the world in the midst of
greed we are called to give up the will
to compete on the false terms of the
world and trust in God to provide in the
midst of violence we are called to give
up our instincts towards
self-preservation to be a beacon of
peace in the battle between religious
voices even we are called to give up our
need to be right in order to seek
instead to see clearly and to love the
stranger in our midst Jesus invites us
to follow not just for ourselves which
is our inclination with all of these
other gods but to follow instead for the
sake of God who loves us and saves us
even from ourselves Jesus goes on to
feed 5,000 in the desert to proclaim
God's kingdom in a way that threatens
all of the local authorities to
dramatically heal people and reinterpret
the Scriptures upsetting all of the
systems that the chief priests have held
in place the crowds would follow they
would love him and fear Him and they
would follow him but they were fickle
and I wonder if he knew even then that
the people would put the Lord their God
to the test opposing and scheming
against him and driving him all the way
to the cross